very loud on business his business has
been slow for months months of
anti-government protests over last
year's disputed presidential election
sometimes made coming to work to sell
his goods difficult constitutional court
judges recently said that vote was
marred by widespread irregularities some
people may have voted more than once
there was ballot stuffing and some
numbers were changed using typewriter
correction fluid they nullified Mays
election results and ordered a rerun the
businessman says living in a country
that seems to always be in election mode
isn't good for his profits it is the
affecting to us as business people you
know to survive here in town we need to
have our businesses to be growing with
unware so it is very difficult for us to
make business after Kenya Malawi is not
the second country in sub-saharan Africa
to recently have a presidential vote
overturned the Court has ruled that
pizza metallica stays in power until a
new election takes place Parliament is
expected to meet within 21 days to set a
date for that election for malaria's it
means more political and economic
uncertainty the opposition is still
celebrating Monday's Court ruling and
many are preparing for a new election
opposition leaders want election
officials fired what the judges have
done is to give Parliament an order to
make sure that what they have ordered in
terms of a fresh election in hundred and
fifty days should happen and so we will
look to Parliament now to make sure that
these things modalities are put in place
and that it is actually possible but I
don't believe that anybody will have
confidence in this electro Commission at
all ruling party officials say they are
considering the options they have two
options the first is to stick in follow
the ruling and they get ready for a
fresh election and that means a lot of
politicking within the party whether
they present a candidate will continue
to be the candidate in the fresh
elections or they want
change and things like that the second
option is for them to go to the Supreme
Court and appeal but they really have to
look very critically had the ruling to
find you know suitable grounds for
appeal if a legal challenge is launched
some here fear it will plunge Malawi
into further crisis haram etosha al
jazeera along